our flags are flying at half-staff in
their memories in the memory of all who
have been lost and for all the families
who have been impacted by covet 19 and
are not we have to remind everyone are
not able to fully gather properly for a
funeral or a memorial and the flags will
continue to fly at half-staff throughout
the duration of this pandemic no family
whether in New Jersey or anywhere will
be forgotten flags in New Jersey flying
at half-staff paying tribute to those
who have died from covered 19 the virus
has killed more than 840 New Jersey
residents as more than 34,000 cases are
confirmed in the state joining us now
with an update is GOP New Jersey
congressman Jeff Andrew congressman
thank you very much for joining us
please do give us an update what are we
looking at in New Jersey right now well
in New Jersey a little bit few New
Jersey's in that the central and
northern half is really a hot spot as
you know and there's a tremendous amount
of activity going on there the southern
district my area is a little bit quieter
there's more spacing to begin with it's
more rural seashore and suburban but
wherever you are you know it's so
important to maintain all the guidelines
new you're supposed to do and let me
just real quickly on the dentist so I
can't help but by nature when we say you
need to wash your hands for 20 seconds
you really do need to do that you need
to really scrub them down create the
friction uses so use the hot water
maintain the spacing if you don't want
mine wearing a mask you're better off
when you go out to wear a mask because
it's just that much more safety for
other folks it was one other thing I
wanted to say on this too something that
we've learned not only in New Jersey
around the world and certainly in the
United States of America and the
president has spoken about it and it's
the simple fact that the supply chain as
good as it's been in certain ways we
need to do better and the president
talked about this in producing and
manufacturing right here in the United
States of America I'd love to see it in
my district but wherever it is we can't
just
why on China for everything that's
something we've really learned and I
think that's going to be all the
sacrifice and all the part of this I
think we make sure god forbid anything
like this happens again
we don't have to rely on another country
it's amazing that all pharmaceuticals
and certain medical supplies and the
ingredients in our pharmaceuticals and
other types of magnifier we are learning
a lot through this that's for sure
congressman I want to get back to the
the flags flying at half-mast for a
second if I can because that picture
that we showed at the beginning of this
segment you know it's really symbolic to
me of the time that we're in right now
and it kind of brings out a little
sadness in me too because you do this
picture here you do think of all of
those family members all the people out
there who've lost loved ones to this
virus and they can't give them a proper
goodbye I mean that that is
heart-wrenching how do you even have a
funeral you're not supposed to hug and
kiss and shake hands and touch each
other so people that are friends and and
and and people that cared about these
other individual human beings so much we
are literally not able physically to
touch the way that human beings normally
do and what I've said is maybe we can't
physically touch because of having that
personal spacing that we need our hearts
and our minds and our souls touch
together this is going to be something
we'll never forget in our lifetime
the last mortgagors ii already than in
9/11 this is a very difficult climb
that's why when it's half-mast that
represents all the people whether they
are doctors first responders bus drivers
people who are even supplying food all
those for people who are on the front
line who are taking a chance for us as
well and willing to actually and some of
them have lost their lives it represents
them as well in congressman we'll keep
you and everyone in New Jersey and our
thoughts because you are a few days it
sounds like from the officials behind
New York thank you for coming on tonight
thank you sir appreciate it
they got it